speaking of people who watch a speech  and don't really see it the way i see it  there's this crazy alcoholic woman named  nancy pelosi and she uh she was sitting  behind biden during this thing and he  was talking about soldiers bringing in  toxic smoke and she really got a kick  out of it  faced in afghanistan faced many dangers  one being stationed at bases breathing  in toxic smoke from burn pits  many of you have been there  i've been doing that  what  can we do it again let's do it here  afghanistan face many dangers  one being stationed at bases breathing  in toxic smoke  from burn pits  [Applause]  what is wrong with these people there's  something wrong with all of them don't  you see it again you all see  something is wrong with these robotic  soulless weirdos what is go what  sorry one more time like what what is  this  that face many dangers  one being stationed at bases breathing  in toxic smoke from burn pits yes  many of you have been there